>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
SO AS WE EXPECTED FROM FAKE NEWS
CNN, BROOK BALDWIN AND DON LEMON
ARE DEFENDING AND TRYING TO
NORMALIZE THE MOB'S BEHAVIOR.
>> WHEN YOU SEE TED CRUZ GETTING
RUN OUT OF RESTAURANTS BY A
MOB --
>> YOU'RE MAD.
YOU'RE MAD.
A MOB?
STOP.
>> THAT IS MOB BEHAVIOR.
>> HOW MANY TIMES HAS THAT
HAPPENED --
>> STOP, STOP.
MATT, WE ALREADY DID THAT.
WE ALREADY SAID THEY WEREN'T
MOBS.
NO, IT'S NOT MOB BEHAVIOR.
I'M PEOPLE UPSET THAT ARE ANGRY
WITH THE WAY THE COUNTRY IS
GOING AND THE POLICIES -- WOULD
YOU LET ME FINISH BEFORE YOU
JUMP IN?
OKAY?
>> Sean: WITH REACTION, AUTHOR
OF THE NEW YORK BEST SELLER,
"TRUMP'S AMERICA", NEWT
GINGRICH.
SO WE WATCH THREE WEEKS OF JUST
THE ABANDONMENT OF ANY DUE
PROCESS AND PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE.
THEN YOU HAVE SARAH SANDERS, PAM
BODY, SECRETARY NIELSON, SENATOR
McCONNELL, BEING CHASED OUT OF
RESTAURANTS.
HILLARY CLINTON SAYS WE CANNOT
AS DEMOCRATS BE CIVIL.
WHEN ERIC HOLDER SAYS WHEN THEY
GO LOW, WE KICK THEM.
WILL THIS WORK IN 27 DAYS?
IS THAT THEIR STRATEGY?
>> WELL, WE'RE SEEING THE
EMERGENCE OF A BROWN SHIRT
PARTY, TO USE THE TERM FOR THE
PEOPLE IN GERMANY WHEN OUT AND
DOMINATED THE STREETS BY BRUTE
FORCE.
THEY CAN'T WIN.
THEY DIDN'T WIN IN THE
PRESIDENCY.
IN MY JUDGE, THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO WIN ON ELECTION DAY AND
THEY'RE BECOMING MORE
HYSTERICAL, MORE
ANTI-DEMOCRATIC, MORE WILLING TO
DESTROY THE SYSTEM.
ABRAHAM LINCOLN WARNED THAT
THERE'S PEOPLE THAT OPPOSE US SO
MUCH IT'S THEIR WAY OR THEY
DESTROY IT.
WE'RE FACED WITH THAT KIND OF
OPPOSITION.
SO LET'S HAVE AN OPEN PUBLIC
DEBATE.
IF YOU THINK PEOPLE LIKE ERIC
HOLDER, HILLARY CLINTON SHOULD
BE ALLOWED TO IMPOSE THEIR WILL
BY BRUTE VIOLENCE, VOTE
DEMOCRAT.
IF YOU THINK THAT'S PROFOUNDLY
WRONG, THEN YOU OUGHT TO VOTE
REPUBLICAN.
>> Sean: WE HAVE RASMUSSEN
TODAY.
REPUBLICANS NOW LEAD DEMOCRATS
BY A HEALTHY MARGIN IN TERMS OF
ENTHUSIASM.
WHAT WAS TWO MONTHS AGO, A HUGE
GAP IN TERMS OF GENERIC BALLOT.
IT'S NOW DEAD EVEN ACCORDING TO
RASMUSSEN.
THERE'S BEEN A DRAMATIC SHIFT
HERE.
SO GOING FORWARD THE NEXT 27
DAYS, YOU'RE A GREAT STRATEGIST,
A GREAT HISTORIAN.
WHAT DO REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES
SENATE AND HOUSE NEED TO SAY TO
DO AND WIN?
>> LOOK, I THINK MAJORITY LEADER
KEVIN McCARTHY HAS GIVEN US A
PERFECT EXAMPLE OF THE KIND OF
CAMPAIGN THAT WE NEED TO WAGE
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS.
HE'S INTRODUCED A BILL THAT SAYS
IF YOU WANT TO STOP FENTANYL FOR
KILLING YOUR CHILDREN, IF YOU
WANT TO STOP MS-13 FROM
TERRORIZING YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD,
IF YOU WANT TO STOP HUMAN
TRACKING, WE HAVE TO CONTROL THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THE OTHER SIDE SAYS, THE
DEMOCRATS SAY NO, NO, WE NEED
OPEN BORDERS, SANCTUARY CITIES,
ABOLISH ICE.
LET'S HAVE A REFERENDUM.
EVERYBODY THAT THINKS WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH CRIME IN AMERICA, WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH DRUGS IN
AMERICA, WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
VIOLENCE IN AMERICA, VOTE
DEMOCRAT.
EVERYBODY THINKS THAT KEVIN
McCARTHY IS RIGHT, WE NEED TO
CONTROL THE BORDER, GET BACK TO
A POINT WHERE OUR CHILDREN AND
NEIGHBORHOODS ARE SAFE, VOTE
REPUBLICAN.
>> Sean: ARE WE BETTER OFF AS A
COUNTRY IN TERMS OF SECURITY?
IS THE ECONOMY BY EVERY MEASURE
BETTER OFF?
WE KNOW THE ANSWER.
IT'S INTERESTING.
YOU WERE ON MY RADIO SHOW.
I MENTIONED IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
GAVIN NEWSOME, YOU WOULD THINK,
IS UP BY 20 POINTS, IT'S NOW
ALMOST WITHIN THE MARGIN OF
ERROR.
JOHN COX A BUSINESS MAN IS
RUNNING AGAINST HIM.
THIS IS A SANCTUARY STATE AND
HE'S OFFERING HELL CARE TO
EVERYONE.
LEGAL, ILLEGAL, THE HIGHLY TAXED
LEVEL OF TAXATION IN CALIFORNIA.
IT PUTS -- ANYBODY THAT GETS
SICK IN AMERICA, GO TO
CALIFORNIA AND THEY'LL TAKE CARE
OF YOU I.
>> I JUST WANT TO SHARE WITH THE
AUDIENCE THAT KNOWS HOW CLOSE
YOU AND I HAVE BEEN FOR ALL OF
THESE YEARS.
YOU BLEW ME AWAY ON THE RADIO
SHOW.
I WAS STANDING THERE GOING, OH,
MY GOD.
THIS IS A NEW WAY OF THINKING
ABOUT IT.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
BASICALLY THE WAY THAT THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE SETTLE IT UP IN
CALIFORNIA, IF YOU'RE IN
TENNESSEE, NEW YORK OR TEXAS AND
YOU HAVE A SERIOUS DISEASE,
GAVIN NEWSOME IS SENDING YOU A
SIGNAL.
COME TO CALIFORNIA AND LET US
PAY FOR IT.
EVERY GOVERNOR IN THE COUNTRY
OUGHT TO BE CAMPAIGNING FOR HIM.
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING -- THEY
HAVE A CHANCE HERE TO SEND EVERY
SICK PERSON IN THEIR STATE TO
CALIFORNIA AND LET NEWSOME DO
IT.
IF I WERE A CALIFORNIAN, I WOULD
THINK THAT'S INSANE.
BUT YOU PICKED IT UP.
I NEVER THOUGHT ABOUT THE
DOMESTIC SIDE OF THAT.
YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
>> Sean: THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE A RESIDENT.
13.5% STATE INCOME TAX RIGHT
NOW.
IT'S GOING TO BE HIGHER.
>> UNDER NEWSOME, IT GETS TO 25.
THAT'S MY PREDICTION I.
>> Sean: OKAY.